saluons va commencer cette petite série
de l'été par une énigme une énigme
tranquille que j'aime bien c'est
l'histoire d'un génie d'un génie qui
maîtrisent pas réellement tous ses
pouvoirs donc autour de lui il se passe
des choses un peu étrange par exemple le
jour il était devant sa table à repasser
parce que oui
les généraux passe contrairement à moi
est repassé le chemise en lin
sauf qu'à un moment donné la chemise
s'est transformé en un chat qui est
parti en miaulant vous me direz c'est
pas très grave mais faut savoir que le
lendemain le génie sort de chez lui il
ferme la porte
il longe le mur de sa maison et le mur
disparaît pour à la place laissée juste
un os un aux deux jambes et ça il ne
maîtrise pas et salah gas alors pour se
changer les idées il part faire du
cheval
il prend la selle email à celle sur le
cheval et à la place de lass elle
apparaît une sorte de gros fromage là on
va pas se mentir et commençait à agacer
g il est un peu triste seul le soir pour
dîner en repenser à tout ce qui s'est
passé ces deux derniers jours et il se
fait il se fait du rite et au moment de
manger le riz le riz se transforme en en
quoi en quoi se transforme le riz oui
c'est ça l'énigme il faut trouver quelle
va être la transformation du riz parce
qu' une logique derrière tout ça je suis
sûr que vous pouvez trouver alors au
départ j'hésitais entre vous donner la
réponse dans deux jours à la prochaine
vidéo ou de vous donner la réponse
maintenant je vais vous la donner
maintenant mais mettez pause pour
chercher ou quitter la vidéo et revenez
la voir une fois que vous avez la
réponse pour vérifier que c'est bon ou
pour avoir la réponse si vous en avez
marre de chercher en tout cas je compte
sur vous pour résister à la tentation de
mettre les réponses dans les
commentaires ce qu'il faut voir tout au
final
attention je vous donne la réponse en
trois deux un maintenant l'assiette de
riz va se transformer en bateau et pour
être très précis ça va se transformer en
ferry il ya une logique derrière tout ça
gueule la logique de la fait parce que
quand on y réfléchit
il repasse et une chemise en lin et ça
s'est transformé en chat et le chat
c'est un fait l'unc ensuite le mur de sa
maison s'est transformée en âne au sein
aux deux jambes parce que fait mûr enfin
je vous ai dit que la cei s'était
transformée en une espèce de fromage
parce que la fée sel est donc en toute
logique le riz va se transformer en
ferry dit moins dans les commentaires si
vous aviez trouvé vous pouvez aussi
proposer des énigmes dans les
commentaires parce que c'est comme ça
c'est l'été on est là pour se marrer
pour 30 vidéos tous les deux jours
jusqu'au 30 août n'oubliez pas de lire
et de vous abonner et puis moi je vous
donne rendez-vous dans deux jours du
coup pour une autre vidéo ciao
[Musique]